[Música]
tengo el momento de revista de prensa
aquí en directo américa de france 24 y
ya está conmigo lista en el estudio rosa
pérez más de euros a bienvenida feliz
martes seguimos entonces en nuestra
semana inició este año 2000 metidos rosa
y abrimos con uno de los temas más
calientes en francia y la política
titula así el media parte eric samur
diseños condenados por injurias racistas
e incitación al odio este artículo lo
escribió camil polonia buenos días
exactamente no como venías comentando en
el noticiero esta fue una condena que
salió ayer y de la que hoy hablan muchos
medios franceses y de alrededor del
mundo y se trata de esta condena a pagar
diez mil euros a la polemista y ahora
también ha candidato a la presidencia de
ultraderecha eric fémur por las palabras
que pronunció en septiembre de 2020 en
la cadena ce news donde era comentado el
cronista de actualidad contra los
menores extranjeros no acompañados bien
la sentencia dice que sus palabras
buscaban crear un ambiente de rechazo y
de violencia contra el conjunto de las
personas
y que la hostilidad que genera que
generan tales declaraciones tienden a
favorecer acciones que se comenten
todavía más fácilmente cuando encuentran
estos discursos como caldo de cultivo y
que más allá de la voluntad expresa de
manifestar su desprecio y de atentar
contra las personas migradas el acusado
pretendía desatar un movimiento de
rechazo y de violencia contra estas
personas bien recordemos que como
acusación civil se llama se personaron
distintas organizaciones civiles no como
ese o ese racismo la liga por los
derechos humanos que piden que esta
condena sirva ya para acabar con la
complacencia de los medios de
comunicación con eric de moore porque lo
que decíamos antes de ser candidato
presidencial y era conocido por su
amplia participación en los medios de
comunicación y cabe recordar también que
esta es la tercera condena contra el ix
de moore y que todavía tiene dos
procesos abiertos y hemos querido sacar
también el artículo que dedicasen news
donde se pronunciaron estas palabras a
ésta misma condena a estos hechos porque
si bien recoge pues la multa que deberá
pagar el ix de moore omite algo que sí
menciona el texto de mediapart y es que
el redactor jefe de the news también
está condenado a pagar una multa de tres
mil euros porque recordemos en los
medios de comunicación hay esta
jerarquía de responsabilidad ante la
justicia de lo que se dice los
contenidos que se difunden pues si son
injuriosos o difamatorios pues no sólo
el periodista debe pagar sino también la
jerarquía que está por encima de él todo
el equipo periodístico que está detrás a
rózsa seguimos con otro medio francés
vamos a ver qué dice lemon que dedica su
editorial al primer ministro británico
boris johnson pues que está en el ojo
del huracán en estas fechas y titula
boris johnson o la cultura de la mentira
también de la fiesta no rosa eso de raúl
y es que bueno recordemos que el reino
unido y francia- no ha venido
atravesando digamos lo que son sus
mejores momentos no que ha habido
distintos puntos de tensión como
recordemos las licencias de pesca el
tema migratorio en el canal d aunque
también la alianza hoy a más a escala
europea el tema del break sheet las
discusiones sobre el protocolo de
irlanda pues esta editorial del mont es
digamos lapidaria contra el primer
ministro británico no pide su dimisión
pero poco le falta y mezcla un poco todo
la gestión de la pandemia con el break
sheet bien empieza recordando a los
lectores que el reino unido
ya supera los 150 mil muertos por la
pandemia y que bien mientras boris
johnson a dictaba restricciones a la
ciudadanía británica el mismo se saltaba
no estas normas que de hecho esta
primera fiesta en downing street tuvo
lugar pocas horas después de que uno de
sus ministros uno de los ministros del
gobierno británico anunciara la
población la prohibición de estas
celebraciones la otra también bueno
digamos muy polémica porque tuvo lugar
la vigilia no de estos funerales del
príncipe felipe duque de edimburgo el
día antes de esta imagen que dio la
vuelta de la reina segunda pues en el
funeral ella sola no entonces digamos
que finalmente da la vuelta a este
editorial y acaba diciendo que pues
boris johnson es un mentiroso que su
constante son las mentiras pero que su
mentira original fue la mentira del
break sit prometiendo al pueblo
británico que el estado daría más ayudas
sociales y a los ultraliberales la
desregulación total de la economía y que
el reino unido deberá pues usar todas
sus competencias democráticas para salir
del callejón sin salida al que abocado
boris johnson rosa brevemente no quiero
que son los que en el tintero el día de
hoy la editorial también de el medio
español el país inhumanidad en
guantánamo exacto es destacable del país
pues dedica su editorial también a
lapidar eeuu por mantener esta cárcel
que tilda de
concebida como un limbo judicial a todos
los efectos se trasladó a personas
secuestradas ilegalmente a terceros
países de países bajo detención
indefinida y sin juicio y se practicaron
torturas por privación del sueño y falso
ahogamiento recuerda y george bush
quería un lugar para mantener a los
detenidos sin la protección del habeas
corpus sin el control constitucional que
prevé la constitución de eeuu ni las
convenciones de ginebra que protegen a
los prisioneros de guerra y dice que así
como obama no pudo cerrarla seguramente
el joe biden tampoco podrá cumplir con
esta que fue su promesa una de sus
promesas electorales